heute sprechen wir über hobbys lukas was
ist dein hobby mein name ist eng spielen
ich interessiere mich davon seit vier
jahren
lukas spielt seit fünf jahren tennis zum
tennisspielen braucht man einen
tennisschläger einen tennisball und
einen tennisplatz victoria was ist dein
hobby meine hobbys musik hören welche
musik magst du ich mag rockmusik
victoria hat kopfhörer mitgebracht die
braucht man zum musikhören und sie hat
verschiedene cd mitgebracht julia was
ist dein hobby mein habe ich momentan
die lange schwimmst du schon seit neun
jahren
julia schwimmt schon seit neun jahren
was ist das das ist eine schwimmbrille
oder auch taucherbrille die brille
benutzt man unter wasser mit der brille
kann man unter wasser sehen
die brille ist sehr klar was ist sein
hobby
nein vom dichten bereitest du auf dem
leichhof magna gibt einmal pro woche auf
einen reiterhof auf dem reiterhof kann
man ver bereiten
wie heißt du olivia olivia was ist dein
hobby mein hobby ist vater präferenz und
nivea hat eine kamera mitgebracht mit
dieser kamera fotografiert oliver oscar
was ist dein hobby mein hobby ist welche
bücher liest du gerne merkel gerne
abenteuerbücher das ist ein buch das
sind
zwei bücher ein erster liest gerne
abenteuerbücher matthäus was ist dein
hobby mein hobby ist wasserbau spielern
matthäus spielt basketball in der
schulmannschaft er dribbelt den ball im
klassenzimmer martin was ist dein hobby
mein hobby ist überspielen
und wer ist dein lieblingsspieler mein
lieblings klar ist nena spielt beim fc
barcelona das war unser video über
hobbys welche hobbys habt ihr schreibt
es uns in die kommentare
und wenn ihr mehr videos den wolf
abonniert easy thermen
[Musik]